you'll notice the person sitting next to
me is meatloaf he's got a new album
braver than we are we weren't sure so
when when we heard you were coming in we
weren't sure do you do we call you meat
meat oh you do mean okay well then I was
right yeah yeah I'll give you the story
she I was born bright bred as a baby and
I couldn't
I stayed bright red and my father was a
Dallas policeman so I'll give you the
I'll give you this story I went as I
mean as far as I've been told and I'll
give you the best accent so my son there
he looks like nine and a half pounds of
ground chuck so I what I what I want you
to do is I want you nurse is to put on
the front of his crib
meet and I'm sure the nurses went oh we
can do that and my dad I'm sure he's in
his uniform when you she can and so you
go ahead and you put meat in that little
slot there's a plastic slot and you move
his crib right into the middle of
everyone else so that when everyone else
come to see their baby they see meat and
that was on my fourth day being of life
well what about it what your name could
have been ground chuck big it could have
been but I don't know how well that
would have worked well meatloaf is a
great great name great stage do it well
they see it when I I got I'm an actor so
they actually use and a football player
I was a football player I was the
meanest football player on my high
school team and I was a walk-on at Texas
Tech but the coaches you yell at me for
being so damn mean I say blow your
whistle ah stop playing and they so they
calm in the program in the football
program it was meatloaf a day number 74
so when you'd make a tackle would be
tackle a meatloaf a day yeah
day or tackle usually they just use a
day okay I don't think the announcers
were ready for meatloaf so I think they
would just go and that tackle was a day
you know are you know more for acting or
music if you're if you're out in public
would people ask you more about what
you've been in movie wise Fight Club or
they ask you about music it's probably
more Matt music but I get I get I do get
asked a lot about sometimes I'm done 61
films and so some people ask me about
films that I'm not bitter coming from
left field and they go I saw you with
Michael Keaton in 1985 I'm going dude
okay so first film was Rocky Horror but
the first film I was ever cast in with
the Taking of Pelham one two three with
Walter Matthau and I was working for Joe
Papp and Joe Papp said yes it's fun but
the director would let me do it and then
I was cast as Billy Bibbit in One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest with Jack
Nicholson oh we were leaving in one
weekend going to Portland
they had a writer's strike and then I
got in Rocky Horror and then ended that
film and then became really good friends
with Lou Adler who produced Carole King
and Jan and Dean and OH
Cheech and Chong and goes on Mamas and
Papas and and owns all of Sunset Strip
and he's a really good friend of mine
and so he helped bring bat out of hell
and we're still talking he sent me he he
they called me the other day they didn't
they were redoing they redid it already
remake for Fox I'm rocking horror and
they called asked if I'd played dr.
Scott and of course when I'm working
they always want me to do a film or a
television or something and I can't do
it because I'm working and so he said I
said who's playing Eddie and he goes
Adam Lambert and I went no he's not like
Oh Adam Lambert is like you know Adam
Lambert's does queen I said Freddie
Mercury was the best rock singer ever to
live and you're telling me
that Adam Lambert who is now singing
with Brian May and Roger Roger is is is
gonna do Eddie I'm going oh my god so I
was like freaking out I'm going oh man
and so Lou sent me I'm answered him yet
I'm going to he sent me the tape of Adam
singing it Adam did a great job but I'm
sorry Adam
I'm still number one do you think so
Freddie is Freddie Mercury the greatest
frontman in rock and roll history I
don't know Matt frontman I I think I'm
one of the best front men in history but
that's just my opinion and I'm entitled
to it and but I think Freddie Mercury
was one of the greatest singer salka in
history and we I had some conversations
I have conversations with different
people about what goes on in stage they
ask me questions I give them answers and
when videos first started I'm not gonna
name names but a lot of major people
we're coming to me going well you shan't
film and and you I don't he shot 12
videos when MTV came on and they said
you've done all this stuff you've
directed and I said yeah and they said
well what do I do I said it's simple
just don't have dead eyes they say well
how do you do that
I said just repeat the song lyrics in
your head and your eyes will never go
dead and the other thing is when you're
live on stage your energy comes from
every part of your body just take all
that energy and put it right in this in
your chest like a laser beam and let it
come out that way it's that simple kids
meet most new album is braver than we
are in collaboration with Jim Steinman
and it's in 429 on 429 records you can
pre-order today on iTunes and Amazon and
there's a few things I wanted to talk to
you about Fight Club was still
fascinating to see that that that you
how would you describe who you were in
Fight Club you know what I can't because
when I when I when you see an actor on
TV and they say to him did you see in
the film and he says oh no I can't watch
myself
Phil that's a dead giveaway he's playing
himself
I can watch every film I never seen me
love there's only been one film and it
was 2 seconds and it was the end of the
day it was the Michael Keaton movie that
I mentioned and the director said all we
want to do is open this door walk
through it go through this door and
close it and I walked at two seconds as
meatloaf and then it's driven me crazy
ever since then so I can watch every
film because I never see me when I'm
talking to you I'm I'm meatloaf yeah I
mean yeah and but when I'm on stage I'm
not when I'm doing films
I'm not when I'm doing records they're
all in character
every one of them is this album was all
sung by a 19 year old and and I had a
guy in email NASA team where you're 68
how can you sing like a 19 year old I go
do you know the word backstory
it's what actors use not everybody but
some I said Ukraine a backstory for the
character and at 19 you stop yeah and so
that's what it is and and people
probably think the last song train alums
about the guy and trying to find a girl
it's not it's about a 19 year old trying
to find out who he is you will you click
sports memorabilia yeah I had an
interview with Dan Rather and I took him
up to my sports room and he couldn't
believe what he was looking at what's
the best thing in there well I got two
things two things that well two years
ago on my birthday Hank Aaron and Derek
Jeter sent me bats for my birthday and
but the two best things are the first
one is I did national anthem at Camden
Yards and so you know we were gonna
leave and they said oh no the owners
want you to come in and so I'm Cal
Ripken was the first one I went to talk
to so I was talking to Cal in Congo's
thank you
I got to give you something I can assign
something for you and he's looking
around him funny he he takes off his
game-worn Jersey and signs it and hands
it to me and I go I can't take that you
could see yeah yeah sure
so that's it the next one is I threw out
the first pitch at Fenway we're just
like everybody knows I'm a Yankees fan
which everybody gave me a really hard
time and I met I was leaving and Ted
Williams was coming out oh wow and they
said Ted this is meatloaf and he knew
who I was and it absolutely freaked me
out that Ted knew who I was and they
said well 10:00 today's meets birthday
and Ted and Ted a little grumpy he goes
well give me a baseball until he signed
the baseball to meatloaf happy birthday
Ted Williams awesome and now I got I'm
gonna finish the story so we gotta get
on the elevator to go down because we're
leaving to get out meet the crowd and
I'll send you guys in black suits get on
and go you guys gotta get off the
elevator and I looked at him I said what
do you think you are Secret Service
anyway yeah okay so we got off and I'm
going I'm waiting I'm go what's going on
and off setting here comes George Bush
Senior who's the president and he comes
walking by and he looks at me and he
gets on the elevator sudden his head
sticks out he goes he goes meet it's
really good president that was one of
the best sports days of my life
and before that Jose Canseco who still
playing for the Ranger yeah had thrown
the ball up into the box we were sitting
in this ball comes flying am come what
the heck I said I look down I see Jose
so I throw him back down I said sign it
and you signed it and threw it back up
so I left with the Ted Williams Jose
Canseco and George Bush go and meet it's
good to be president his new album is
braver than we are
it's great to have you I'd love to have
you in again and spend more time talking
to you yeah babies when we are is
completely different and we did it on
purpose
then better than hell and there's a
doctor's prescription for it
it's like you buy it listen to it once
and four times take it four times during
the day at the end of then you don't
know it's genius
well I'm glad you stopped by it's it's
great to see you man
you can pre-order the album today on
iTunes and Amazon meat loaf or as we
like to call it meat and Dan but two out
of three that could be a baseball term
but two out of three well they use it
all the time okay in baseball
all the time man the Cubs man has used
it the other day three times the Orioles
man all the managers abused it and
Mattingly uses it who's a friend of mine
because we did it we did a meatloaf of -
I did a meatloaf honor thank you for
coming on the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience